[Musique]
j'aime pas que divers pense que c'est
trop triste et puis des fois on s'ennuie
son papa et maman une fois pas et puis
je trouve ça malheureux
moi je suis contre mais c'est pas mais
ma tante et les divorcés et pis je pense
ça et qu'elle avait raison de divorcer
parce que son mari gelé pas vrai moi non
plus je n'aimais pas comme campello
pourquoi tu penses à c'est pas bien
parce que j'aime bien mes parents et
puis si gentil tu rien je voudrais
travers ce récit qui très vite je
voudrais être avec la et puis comme j'ai
un petit frère
j'ai peur que mon petit frère ne
viennent pas avec je veux où je viens et
belges que j'aime bien mon petit frère
non je pense que de le défendre c'est un
petit peu triste et puis des fois que
mon père monde se dispute moi ça me fait
pleurer je m'en tombent
puis je pleure puis des fois mais sur le
fond s'est disputée jeudi arrêté mais
villepin ont été des mois la demande un
peu pourquoi exact
moi j'aimerais bien savoir super six
si par exemple il mêle guichet on
pourrait essayer de les arranger les
choses
tu penses qu'un enfant a son mot à dire
dans une décision par exemple de
séparation un peu et quand elle est
distincte et arrive quelquefois d'avoir
peur de que tes parents divorcent oui
mais on perd papin quand il ya des
disputes et unique nation ale et qu'est
ce que tu penses à ces mois
on ne sait pas très bien dire ça parce
que moi parfois ça me fait pleurer puis
tu veux pas pleurer quand on s'entend
plus vraiment bien parce qu'il s'est
passé quelque chose de grave là je suis
d'accord mais quand c'est pour une toute
petite chose suis pas d'accord je pense
que les parents doivent faire des
efforts oui mais au début j'ai un peu
déformé mais après ça quand je commence
à m'habituer à déprimer c'est à dire on
peut très bien ce qu'il fallait faire
c'est pas moi j'ai oublié des choses ont
bien dit comme ça joue bien il est trop
préoccupé à part ça est-ce que tu avais
envie quand même de le redire mais enfin
c'est à cause de vous que je suis comme
ça non je veux leur dire ça pourquoi
parce que je pensais que je peux vous
quoi mais je crois que c'est pas de leur
faute mais ça a été comme ça ma mère
vous avez invité à côté de sa mère comme
beaucoup de gens veulent j'ai rien à me
reprocher c'est quelquefois tu as eu
peur qu'il ne t'aime plus
oui parfois est-ce qu en général tu
penses que les parents quand ça va pas
ils doivent se séparer les divorcés ben
non maman elle devrait essayer de
résoudre le problème
et après si ça va toujours plus loin
encore en discuter
si tu racontes on est mal mon mieux tu
penses qu'à passer discussions dans le
couple ou à la haye ce que tu as eu
envie qu'on te demande ton avis non
parce que je sais que je n'aurais pas pu
répondre à ça mais je savais bien qu'ils
allaient devoir s'expliquer c'est un peu
moi tu crois que c'est à cause de toi je
suis sure they can
pourquoi on est déçu parce que à chaque
fois un moment un disciple on va te dis
c'est l'heure d'aller au lit mon père
disait bon matelas qui a précipité à
cause de moi j'étais malheureuse que ce
que je croyais tout petit mais pour moi
mais je ne sais pas si oui ils avaient
raison de ce divorce est minime mais moi
pour moi il avait pas raison je veux te
marier plus tard toi pourquoi parce que
tout le temps mais auquel on a fait ça
et puis ce n'est pas vrai c'est pas bien
c'est simple si un enfant d'à après il
sera obliger tous les circuits 6 il
prend 1 er temps ça m'embêterait mois et
si pour moi et pas moi je n'arriverai
pas à le supporter toute seule
[Musique]